wie ist die Lage die Lage ist
unverändert gut kann man sagen
unverändert positiv heißt dass es eine
gewisse Kontinuität in deiner Existenz
gibt ja auf jeden Fall ich meine ich
habe ja immer
m ich habe einen sehr großen guten Stamm
an
zuhören die nicht abhängig sind
von der medialen Verwurstung also wie
ich gerade in den Medien erscheine und
das ist schon mal sehr klasse und
aber in erster Linie bezieht sich das
unverändert gut auf die Musik an sich
also nicht auf das existenzielle sondern
aber also das existenzielle ist ja die
Musik also nicht aus auf die Versorgung
sondern ähm das Musik machen mit der
Band das ist unverändert gut das ist
total jetzt die zweite Tour in dies
Besetzung und das bringt jeden Abend
dermaßen Spaß das finde ich manchmal
schon
beschämend warum bist du denn nie diesen
Weg den ja viele andere gegangen sind
gegangen so jetzt will ich mal richtig
absahen ich mache jetzt mal ein Album
das durchgestylt ist auf eine bestimmte
Zielgruppe hin mit einem bestimmten
Marketing und
das macht mir auch Spaß vielleicht nicht
so viel aber ich verdiene mehr Geld
warum hast du das nie gemacht
da schwanke ich in der Erklärung da bin
ich nicht so eindeutig das hat mit
meiner Herkunft zu tun zum Teil dass ich
mich immer
m also nie so irgendwo verwurzelt
gefühlt habe meine Eltern sind aus
Schlesien ich bin in Hamburg geboren bin
dann da rausgerissen worden ins
Ruhrgebiet habe mich wie viel Jahren mit
fünf ja habe mich im Ruhrgebiet
eigentlich nie wirklich wohlgefühlt also
schon mit den Leuten natürlich bin da
groß geworden und ich verstehe was da
abgeht und bin da auch gerne aber ich
hatte nicht so diese gesellschaftliche
Verwurzelung also über Familie irgendwo
eingebunden zu sein und ich glaube das
hat damit zu tun dass ich damit immer so
ein bisschen mich außerhalb gesehen habe
und gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen
bin keine Ahnung und vielleicht oder das
ist eine Erklärung die andere wäre das
mir das immer schnurzpiep egal war und
ich immer eigentlich nur Musik machen
wollte aber du hast ja warst ja bei
Major Labels und hast das auch zu weilen
mal hingeschmissen und gesagt nee ja ja
genau das das war's dann also ich habe
immer Pickel gekriegt wenn mir da einer
reinreden wollte und habe
eigentlich immer mir selber also eine
zweite Erklärung wäre wirklich Mangel
selbst Bewusstsein z.B was ja anders
erscheint Absol dass man sagt der ist ja
total Selbstbewusstsein er zieht das
durch
zum Teil hat es aber mit mangelen
Selbstbewusstsein zu tun dass ich mich
immer wieder selber in Situation
gebracht habe und mir immer wieder
Brücken ab abgerissen hab und oder
Möglichkeiten selber verstellt hab ne
wenn man ein Problem hat dann wiederholt
man ja immer und das war mir ganz viele
Jahre gar nicht so bewusst und ich habe
mir selber immer eine Falle gestellt
oder ein Beinchen wie z.B z.B war das
das ähm mit Dumpfbacke mit dem Album
happy im lalaland da hatten wir ein
verhältnismäßig großen Erfolg in den
Medien we du und
ähm danach habe ich z.B gegen Anraten
der Plattenfirma die mich bekniet hat
das nicht zu tun habe ich ein
Instrumentalalbum
rausgebracht quasi altes Publikum hier
kommt jetzt das be
ich ganz anderes und das wäre sehr
wichtig gewesen da dran weiterzumachen
und ja das war aber ich ich konnte auch
da gar nicht anders ich wollte dieses
Instrumentalalbum ist das so ein zweites
ich in dir was dem anderen ich immer ein
Beinchen stellen will ja das kann kann
sein und wie überzeugt das zweite ich
dann das andere ich dass das jetzt was
machen muss was eigentlich gar nicht
so kruktiv vielleicht ist was produktiv
ist aber vielleicht nicht was die
Karriere betrifft konstruktiv ja das ist
das überzeugt natürlich über das Gefühl
weil das ist ja nicht falsch es ist ja
nicht nur ein Kranker Impuls alles
kaputt zu machen sondern ist ja
verknüpft mit
einem richtigen emotionalen Drang zur
Musik eben über die Musik und damit kann
es mich natürlich überzeugen und dafür
hätte ich auch eine Erklärung wo ich
erst vor kurzen drauf gekommen bin ich
habe ähm
mit 12 Jahren ist mein Vater gestorben
das war ein sehr schmerzhaftes Erlebnis
ich hatte mir vorher schon seitdem ich
Zeh war zwei Jahre wirklich intensivs
eine Gitarre gewünscht und habe die aber
nicht
nicht Ruhe ich habe die aber nicht
kriegen gekriegt weil wir einfach das
Geld dafür nicht hatten und als mein
Vater gestorben ist hat mir dann meine
Mutter wirklich die letzten Kröten
zusamm gekratzt um mich zu trösten und
mir diesen Wunsch erfüllt und dann W es
mir erst wirklich vor ein paar Jahren
klar oder vor z D Jahren diese diese
Verknüpfung in mir den Schmerz zu haben
den Vater verloren zu haben und
aber sich tierisch zu freuen und ich
glaube dadurch ist auf jeden Fall eine
eine Verpflichtung dem Instrument
gegenüber also der Tiefe des Instruments
des musikmens bei mir entstanden und von
daher kon
das immer in also war das immer die die
Hauptaussage oder der der Grund nachdem
ich mich gerichtet habe das heißt wenn
du größtes Glück empfindest bist du auch
deiner tiefsten Trauer am nächsten
ja und und ich ja also wenn so
Entscheidung wie du gerade gesagt hast
warum höre ich auf die eine Stimme die
mir ein Beinchen stellen will wenn das
damit verknüpft ist mit dem Argument das
ist aber doch jetzt dein Begehren diese
instrumentalplatte zu also mach sie
dann höre ich natürlich darauf weil ich
dann diese Verpflichtung spüre ich muss
an dieser an der dieser Tiefe bleiben so
das heißt wenn Du Erfolg hättest mit
etwas mit dem du nicht wirklich hinter
dem du nicht wirklich 100% Kön würde ich
nicht aushalten nicht würde ich
wahnsinnig werden und das ist eben dann
auch so auf der Bühne auch wenn ich mit
Leuten stehe die die nicht wirklich auf
meiner Wellenlänge sind oder das
verstehen oder auch auch rein von
anderen Ansichten her man sich versteht
könnte ich das nicht wirklich wahnsinnig
werden durch diesen Tod bist du mit
einer Ernsthaftigkeit mit Musik
beschäftigt die vielleicht so gar nicht
entstanden wäre ansonsten glaube ich ja
das ist natürlich für Leute die mich
kennen zum Teil schwer zu verstehen weil
ich ja sehr viel lustige Sachen mach und
deswegen das hat mir
auch deswegen hat das auch so lange
gedauert bis ich selber da drauf
gekommen bin weil ich dachte was so
lustige Sachen aber das
hat auch wiederum genau damit zu tun
weil wenn ich intensive Sachen
mach dann ich bin immer kurz vom Heulen
also wenn ich wirklich was ganz ganz
intensiven Moment auf der Bühne dann
dann
Ringe ich mit den Tränen und das muss
ich mit lustigen Sachen brechen also ich
könnte gar nicht ein ganzen Abend
intensive ich muss meine Balladen die
ich mache und meine ganz intensiven
Songs muss ich immer dazwischen streuen
und brauche immer wieder die lustige
Ablenkung wo es dann mehr um Rhythmus
und um Spaß geht um ja nicht wirklich da
zu sitzen Rabe wieso hast du machst du
die Musik die du
machst das ist natürlich eine ganz tolle
Frage ja du könnst was anderes machen du
könnst Swingmusik machen regy klar
gibt's auch eine ganz einfache
Erklärung ich
bin mit der Musik Ende der 60er alles
was im Radio lieg
habe ich quasi auf die Festplatte
gebrannt gekriegt weil ich einen vier
Jahre größeren Bruder habe wir in einem
Zimmer zusammen waren und der hat
nachtsimmer BFBS gehört der weil ich
schlief und morgens stand ich dann an
der
Bushaltestelle nein hast diese Lieder
und hat dann irgendwie alles im Kopf und
wusste gar nicht wo das alles herkam
also das war so richtig eingebrannt aber
warum sind sie nicht
englisch das hat auch eine ganz klare
Erklärung weil ich dann 67
68 mich Hendrix wirklich am meisten
gepackt hat und ich gemerkt habe dass es
ja gar nicht nur der Rhythmus oder der
Style oder irgendwie was ist sondern
dass es die Intensität ist die mich
wirklich packt ich habe seine Gitarre
verstanden ich habe bin drauf abgefahen
wie er wirklich die Töne modelliert und
wie man wirklich das Gefühl von ihm
raushören konnte und das hat mich völlig
umgehauen dann habe ich angefangen das
äh nach hab versucht das eben
nachzuspielen konnte das auch rein
technisch ziemlich schnell und habe aber
gemerkt das ist es nicht und also mich
faszinieren nicht die Akkordfolgen oder
die Tonfolgen sondern mich fasziniert
das Gefühl und das an das Gefühl komme
ich nicht ran wenn ich das nachmach und
dann habe ich eben in der
Weiterentwicklung gemerkt da komme ich
auch nicht dran wenn ich Englisch singe
auch wenn ich eigene Tex weil es nicht
meine Sprache ist und dann habe ich
gemerkt ich muss meinen eigenen Rhythmus
und meine eigenen Melodien finden und
das hieß Deutsch ja ist ja ganz klar
super dann so noch viel Erfolg wie lange
willst du noch auf der Bühne stehen die
obligatorische Frage will ich Umfall du
B du Umfall also horizontal nein also so
das was ich vorhin alles gesagt habe
dass ich mich auf der Bühne am am besten
fühle das verändert sich natürlich auch
so weil ich entwickle mich ja weiter
also ich habe nicht den Traum auf der
Bühne zu sterben also möchte ich nicht
möchte ich weder mein Publikum
zumuten ne noch
mir selber also ich werde aber mit
Sicherheit wirklich solange ich kann
Musik live auf der Bühne machen gut dann
noch viele erfolgreiche Touren und keine
längeren Pausen als 5ün Wochen richtig
und kein off day wähend der Tour sehr
gut